uh some of the flavors
associated with classic lady the things
like fresh mint lemon drops fresh cut
wild flowers what creates
the flavors of something that clearly
isn't in the whiskey where does that
come from
uh so the same chemical that is clearly
mint
and is in mint
is also present in other ways and other
things
so like for example there's a chemical
called isoamyl acetate
because
you would know it as banana
yeah right yeah yeah so that chemical is
in banana that's what makes banana taste
like banana that chemical also shows up
in grain yeast and grain yeast
fermentations
right
and if especially if done badly it can
dominate and you get this whiskey that's
vaguely banana
smelling this is intriguing daniel
because my friend here to my right
dominic monahan
oh yeah he just he he bought me a book
you're obsessed with this book this book
i'm obsessed with is called the body by
bill bryson
and uh bryson is a damn genius
have you read this book the body yeah
when it just goes through all the
different parts of your body and i was
just reading
about taste buds
and chemicals and how you taste
different things and
basically
they don't yet know because it's it's
it's it's one of the um
senses that they haven't looked really
closely at but it's what you're talking
about it's basically same thing with the
nose a chemical yeah a chemical is in a
banana but it sends something else so we
just go banana but it's actually just a
chemical touching your
um tastebud
and hold me back all through the night
you're shining bright i'm your host
[Music]